man ain't ya thanks so much for coming
on the show my pleasure
you know people don't realize you guys
are right about two floors away that's
where you do start out live absolutely
and we saw we see you from time to time
but it's rare we get to have you here on
the show right here in person that's
right you know actually I don't know
much about you I know a bunch of the
people in sanitized I don't know much
about you personally you are from
whereabouts from Southern California I
grew up in Irvine yeah
[Applause]
what the hell is that would you go to
school I went to to University of
Southern California in Los Angeles where
I was a sports information major so wait
a minute what is that yeah that's a I
thought a real mate where is it was I'm
one of the first and last graduates in
sports information yeah so what is
sports information it was it was like it
was kind of like sports broadcasting in
a way but we we had classes like I had
to take like volleyball and are you
kidding no I took volleyball like twice
I think that was that was a class yeah
so you took client you really took
classes I really did yeah and like
history of sports literally so yeah the
football is differently than the
baseball 100 yards in a football fields
yeah true did you were you a goofball
and we were a funny guy when you were in
college
yeah I was I was a funny guy at least I
thought I was I would one of my favorite
things I'd like to do is I had a friend
who was my friend email which is a funny
name and he I got a stupid name - Conan
a Nemo together and been beaten up yeah
so you know actually looks like you a
little bit really it's good I'm big so
you know ISM there's really this English
class that I would I would dress up like
a janitor and just walk into the middle
of the class and the teacher would go
excuse me can I help you and I just say
it nobody threw up in here I'm sorry I
got a phone call down to physical and
they said a young a young man threw up
here and I'm sorry and I would leave and
then I came back a couple other times
the teacher actually enjoyed it had me
come back a couple a couple more times
right I like doing this I'm taking a
volleyball class yeah is a complete
waste of time
go to USC that's a good commercial for
them are there you know you guys up it
certain lever all ways working on
characters you're gonna do that on the
showed you got any characters that
you're working on this summer actually
cool and I do I have a couple characters
that been trying to to get on mm-hmm
this is just simply cat guy which I'd
like to what is you need to explain that
guy he's basically a guy at dinner
parties who just you'll see okay okay
let's see cat yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well this is good eggs and that for cat
guy personally alright now you you
perform for the this is this gonna sound
like a joke but you actually part of an
improv troupe and you perform for the OJ
juries that's right that's right The
Groundlings theater in Los Angeles which
you've done some work with that's right
and we actually went and performed for
the jury in like the adjacent courtroom
this is back when they were trying to
you know that the jury was sequestered
and they needed exactly and they were
like you know just everyone felt sorry
for him cuz they were just going back
and forth and so we literally did you
know I did like cap guy in front of them
in a courtroom
yeah and they starting to explain their
verdict so now there's one you you guys
have something that we Envy here at this
show we do our show non-stop right right
it never ends but you guys have a whole
summer off the show you stop taping in
late May it's and then you don't start
till mid-september right right what are
you doing with your summer are you doing
anything well I'm actually doing
something that's very dear and near to
me it's actually a one-man show it's
performance art which which I really
enjoy in fact I'd like to do a piece if
you don't mind
this is why this is a little piece that
up
thank you I called summer in Central
Park and and this is about you're gonna
perform this yeah I think you'll enjoy
it I'm actually performing it in the
park okay all right
[Music]
summer Central Park
you ripped my heart
[Music]
[Music]
summer in Central Park
[Music]
[Applause]
see that yeah you're gonna do well with
that well barrel everybody thank you
very much you don't owe me three coming
up you want to see them perform follow
me